[Laughter]
get your eyes on the rock
oh you know how mad I'd be watching
she's like you woke me up she's like I
should have drunk candy
she said
I can't stand deep time deep time this
is like Harry riding a hippogriff
was a lot more a lot smaller a lot
smaller and a lot smaller a lot easier
to control uh welcome back to New
Rockstars it's time for morning and
drift Mark but it isn't long before the
kids start scrapping and someone losing
the damn eye but is this the last of the
Bloodshed for the generation of Westeros
royalty I don't think so
now with that slash this is big question
presents talking dragons our weekly
fantasy after show play my Graphics it
is our weekly uh Talking Dragon show
where we talk about Game of Thrones and
we talk about anything that involves
Dragons I'm Jessica Clemens here today
with Brandon Barrick hello yes what an
episode what a wild wild episode I
really like uh six and seven as like a
pair like the last episode
episode now this one and now we're going
to get another time Jump for the kids
I'm more excited for the next time yeah
I like these two episodes together they
were wild they were so wild I love every
episode oh I know what a show well let's
not waste any more time let's smear some
blood on our faces and pledge our future
fiery death together to episode 7 of
House of the Dragon titled driftmark
it's time for lady Lena's funeral at
driftmark sorry
I came in so excited just I know what
the worst news dude the music during
that funeral was so sad I was really
moved I was more like I was like I
understand you guys own the oceans but
like dumping your bodies right there and
there's a village there's a pile I'd
rather you get her a little ship and
then like put it out a little bit and
then let it sink yeah maybe poke a
little hole I did when I saw that I was
I was thinking like oh 2 000 years from
now like are there all the
archaeologists in Westeros are gonna be
like oh what a great little find we
found down here
um so everyone from King's Landing has
Comfort come in for this ceremony
including Otto who's back as hand of the
king good to see our boy back I mean
they could use like a fresh haircut it's
almost like they grabbed him up the
street he's a little cleanup but uh he's
really happy to be back uh and I must
say five dragons at once seeing five
dragons on the screen at one time I was
trying to figure out who who all the
dragons were because I don't even think
we see vegar there we see we definitely
see like caraxis and Cyrax is there I
think we see maybe a Moon Dancer who's
Bayless Dragon uh and Sunfire who's uh
amon's dragon I don't know if we see or
I'm sorry aegon's Dragon uh I don't know
if we see melees who is uh raynesia's
dragon because they're at driftmark so I
don't know if their dragons are out
hanging around I don't know it's tough
to say but I feel like when in doubt you
can probably assume that they were so
smart I was like which second is that
what dragon is that I don't know
um well Vibes at this wake are not good
you keep coming in I know it's so
awkward it's very windy it's like windy
as hell we had to turn on the closed
captioning because like everyone's kind
of whispering no one wants to be there
or even like talk to one another uh
young Jace wants to be at sir harwin's
funeral because he knows that's his dad
he's like why are we there uh but
Rainier has to remind him that way and
it was family and break bones was not
family officially uh genetically he's
family but officially he's not so we got
to be here my guy also go be nice to
your cousins yeah aegon wants to be
somewhere else with like a lady or two
or however many long-legged ladies long
leg of mighties uh Damon looks bored and
ready to move on he he does chuckle
during the eulogy uh which I thought was
funny well he kind of does it because
the guys like saying like uh at least
half of this family is in the right
bloodline as he's looking at uh the
brunette headed children over there and
uh Damon gets a little chuckle out of
that
Allison and Sir Kristen Cole both want
to kill Rainier they're both like still
angry Lenor is in his feelings in the
ocean just kind of vibing hanging out uh
having a bad time his sister's dead he's
depressed uh and viserys himself just
wants to be dead already he's so old he
just wants to go home and play with his
little model Valeria and get out of here
uh he's even closer to death than he's
been at any other point if that's even
believable I don't know how this guy's
alive he calls Allison Emma at one point
as he's heading off to bed which is like
all right so Kristen Cole's eyes got so
big and I was like yeah stop in
everyone's business I was like back up
at least 20 feet Kristen Cole stop being
in there he's always hovering uh viserys
and Damon try to bond over dead wives uh
Damon's got two at this point uh but
viserys isn't really happening yet or
Damon's not really having it telling
viserys basically God's not been very
kind to you uh but Sarah's tries to
invite him back to King's Landing come
join the court come come back I'm sorry
I banished you twice but Damon wants
nothing to do with him and just tells
him it's so funny that scene was
actually genuinely like I don't care
yeah I don't oh my God after the party
winds down rainey's confronts Corliss on
his desire for the throne and what it's
cost their family he claims he's done it
all for his wife the queen that never
was but when rainey's uh reveals she
wants the line of the Lord of driftmark
to pass to Bayla she knows renera's kids
are not laners and thus not valerian
the scene this was wild this scene I
loved okay yeah because this is this is
my favorite line I want it tattooed on
my body Coral this is when I realize
Corliss is maybe my favorite character
okay and I it took me too long to
recognize it Corliss box at this and he
says back to her history does not
remember blood it remembers names which
is wild though but it's kind of wild
because his own granddaughter he's like
well let's not make her the the Lord of
driftmark well we got this perfectly
good boy over here and my niece is like
hey you claim to be doing all this
because I didn't get the lineage and now
you won't give it the thing is though
it's not it's not a which is I know it's
not about her being a woman it's about
the fact that that one's closer to being
a king than this one but it's also like
that one clearly uh has no Valerian
blood yeah yeah no that one it makes
it's wrong it's wrong but I just love
that line of like it's true No One's
Gonna though maesters are like let me
write down that this genetically and
this is very he talks about Legacy and
like you know we're only on this Earth
for a little bit so we've got to arrange
our pieces for our Legacy which is like
a very Tywin Lannister thing right I'm
doing this for my family but it's like
really you're doing this for your family
my guy I don't know it's yeah he keeps
reminding himself that he's doing it for
his wife and I'm like you're reminding
yourself she's tired of that reasoning
for her kids dying she's like I'm sick
of this yes please stop killing my
children okay so the irony being that we
saw earlier at the wake uh that lucerius
doesn't want to be the Lord of driftmark
his reason being that if he were so it
would mean everyone else would die which
is sweet but still my boy because at
first he's like I don't want to be the
Lord you're like come on boy do your
stuff he's like because everyone would
be dead it's like oh okay I guess I get
it
that I'm sorry that's just your life my
dude that's the hard part is just being
a child and being have to reckon with
like you're gonna probably die because
you're fighting for your family right uh
Rainer and Damon go for a long walk on
the beach my favorite drink Damon
insinuates that Otto and Allison were
behind the Harren Hall fire she
confronts Damon for leaving her alone
for 10 years yeah it's they both compete
over who had the worst marriage Damon
doesn't say he loved Lena but that they
were happy enough which was like it's
tough it was tough
Elsa because Elena is not bad Elena is
that like the only person in the show
where I was like this is a good person
just set up for disaster Rayner reveals
that she and Leonard did try to have
kids but there was no joy in it it
didn't work it did not work and he even
I like that conversation because we were
even speculating like did they try yeah
yeah did they even try but they did try
they did try and Damon is really sweet
here
and that he acknowledges like I get to
mourn my wife my love my wife in public
you you don't get to mourn Harwin at all
like you can't do that publicly that's
true and he him acknowledging that again
like kind of sweetens right nearer to
him but it's clear like rhaenyra has
been thinking about him and wants to be
with him even though she was groomed as
a child she'll like love this man she
does genuinely have feelings for him and
she's had the time to be like look I had
10 years and I still want you that's the
deal my God that's so hard because even
when you're watching I would say she
makes the first move oh she absolutely
does oh she absolutely does but when I
was watching I was like it must be weird
to have your uncle like talk to you or
entirely she calls him Uncle it was like
okay afterwards she's okay cool I said
no I said let's drop the uh the family
name
names rhaenyra reveals her desire for
Damon has not Wayne they find a cozy if
you want to call it cozy a little open
wooden shipwreck
we could go back here where no one can
see a drift Mark of their own
beaches yes
well there were two butt prints we laid
side by side but when there were only
one set of butt prints yeah you were on
top of them no you were on top of them
uh Brandon Rice's great joke I have to
mention it and do some coupling on the
beach now they finally did some coupling
and they finally sealed the deal now
Allison can be mad she can be mad and
boy is she mad uh on another part of the
island I thought for a second Eamon was
watching them but he wasn't yes thank he
was watching a sleeping Dragon he wants
to do a little how you train your dragon
of his own uh he sleeps out he sneaks up
on Vega who's sleeping who doesn't
really see him as a threat at first
which I I really liked like he grabs the
thing beggar looks is like oh it's just
you get out of here and he does it again
and the dragon's like okay you want to
touch me I'm gonna I'm gonna boot up he
starts charging up the old fire uh fire
mouth uh but our boy eamon's been
practicing his high valarian commands
and he hops on for a ride he basically
tells vegar I'm doing this and vegar you
know tests him to see Vegas like cool
get on she's like all right I'm gonna
give you the hard ride and he all done
so she's like all right I guess you
could be my my writer now uh Bella Reyna
Jace and Luke confront Eamon when he
lands they find him in a tunnel uh and
Reina was planning to claim her mother's
Dragon remember she doesn't have a
dragon her egg didn't hatch uh so she
was like I'm gonna do that it was mine
and eamon's basically like you snooze
you lose okay dragon's sitting there
someone's got to claim it that's how it
works you don't just get to have your
parents Dragon you gotta go claim okay
he also calls Rainier as kids bastards
for good measure uh and so the kids get
into some fisticuffs and Eamon winds up
losing an eye my young boy Luke does it
the little the youngest crashes
I love Damon I mean I saw him and pick
up that rock and I was like he's about
to bash his child's head in oh it's a
bloody kids fight hey as long as Damon's
daughter got that good licking you got a
good punching she knocked him she was
the one that knocked him and we know the
boys have been having fight training
from Sir Kristen Cole and uh break bones
R.I.P uh but you know the girls we don't
know if they've had much fight no I
assume Damon knows how women are treated
in this world is like I'm gonna teach
you how to defend yourself I hope right
especially Elena too I'm sure Elena was
like you're gonna know how to defend
yourselves but they're not getting the
constant fight training so we saw it all
play out here after the scuffle all the
families come together in the Hall of
nine including Rainier and Damon with
sand still in their britches oh I
couldn't find them uncle
[Laughter]
viserys tries to calm the situation down
because again he just wants to die
everyone shut up when it comes out that
the bastard was thrown around about the
future air he wants to know where this
rumor came from uh he confronts aymond
about it and says like your king is
asking this is his son he's like he says
this is your king asking you uh uh Ayman
says aegon told him but just like
classic little brother stuff like uh the
uh and amen aegon's still drunk and he's
like uh what's happening I don't know
what's going on and aegon basically is
like we all know their bastards death I
mean he's eamon's looking at you know
Allison viserys is clocking this he
knows Allison has been uh spreading this
as well but uh aegon does the smart play
and it's like dad everyone knows come on
get it together but Sarah says that's
enough bastard talk and any more will
cost their speaker their tongue and we
know they love to cut out tongues and
Westeros Allison demands one of Rayner's
son's eyes in return a literal iPhone
and tell sir Kristen Cole to take one of
luceras's eyes viserys denies her this
and Kristen Cole doesn't even move he's
like listen I love Allison you're my
you're my number one uh I don't think
you saved me from killing myself but I'm
not about to cut out a kid's eye uh so
uh Allison decides to do it herself she
grabs the the infamous cats par dagger
the Valerian still dagger that we know
so well to take the eye for herself and
winds up slicing Rainier's arm in the
struggle that ensues I also love Crystal
Cole when it's like oh we're gonna
attack Ramirez I'm in Damon immediately
stops I was like I'm not cutting out a
little kid's eye but we're gonna cut up
renira let's go let's go yeah I love
Damon stepping in there like uh-huh I
love Damon style and I I love which
isn't okay ever no one stopped this yeah
no not a single person
get this over with when Allison's like
you serve me to Sir Christian Cole and
uh uh sir Harold westerling the head of
the kingsguard kind of looks at Crystal
goal is like what's all this you
have you not noticed this yet like my
guy you're asleep at the wheel this is a
problem you gotta deal with your men
your men are going wild yeah Buck Wild
having sex with everybody killing people
trying to rip children's eyes you guys
are out of your mind you gotta get your
King's Garden order in order they are
loose all over the place like
so we see Rainier and Allison kind of
struggling here this is a shot from the
trailer we've been knowing this was
coming Rainier uh gives the line here
she says exhausting isn't it hiding
beneath the cloak of your own
righteousness but now they see you as
you are and it's true Allison has shown
what's been bubbling under the surface
all this time everyone knows what's up
uh and that's how all that commotion
ends Amon has the smart move here he
ends all this stuff before it gets any
further uh with an act of conciliation
he says I may have lost an eye but I
gained a dragon and what a dragon he
gained also he could have said that a
little earlier yeah
you know could have been like it's okay
I lost his eye I'm not too mad yeah yeah
you almost got your mom killed by being
like she told me she told me my mother
okay so Otto approves of his grandson
settling the matter he also approves of
Allison's tenacity telling her later
that she didn't know that he didn't know
that she had it in her yeah uh which
I'm so mad he had to scoop up his wasted
older grandson earlier uh in the day so
I think he sees a true king yeah yeah
which I think he's so sick of egg on it
he's like ammon's my guy now yeah
he's my little one-eyed boy no spoilers
and if need be Allison always has her
pet psychopath lyrics
question is like greatly needed in the
future you can steal a kid's eye maybe
later maybe earlier with sir Crystal's
like let's keep staring at you and she's
like oh yeah don't worry don't worry
about that uh
she says cool the guy that keeps ripping
people's tongues out is staring at you
like you're a a platter yeah
make me a quilt with everyone's family
everyone's family and I I will love it
forever okay so laying our shows up late
to everything the next morning
good morning you hear this little gimboy
uh I should he says I should have been
there he says those should be our um
okay and then they say those should be
our house words Rainier replays I love
that line like I should have been a
those should be our Housewives you know
what I don't even care because the
ending laner wants to recommit to the
marriage and be a better husband he
tells renera you deserve a husband I
mean he gets rid of everything those are
very key lines I mean if you know book
readers are no one he says that like you
deserve a husband it's like uh you know
it's coming next and we see what happens
in this episode you deserve her husband
but there's more to it you deserve a
husband yeah
yeah okay well rhemara takes those words
you deserve a husband to heart and
proposes to Damon her uncle and hi
Valerian uh to Wed and go up against the
greens she says the greens uh you know
obviously the height the House of
hightower's Color but something they're
going to become to known as like the
greens but what do we do about this
still living Lenor even Damon's like
well I can't quite marry you yet you
still have a husband uh well Damon makes
sir Carl an offer he can't refuse a
beautiful life across the sea rich as
hell doing whatever you want doing
whoever you want he there he makes sir
Carl very publicly attack Lord Lenor at
driftmark uh and leave him dead in a
fireplace for his parents to find Lenor
is yet another Valerian to meet a fiery
and just like his sister or is he we end
the episode with an old school Targaryen
wedding in private with very traumatized
kids looking on I mean these girls just
lost their mother and is now seeing
their father marrying his niece and
that's their aunt right or their cousin
it would be like their cousin yes yes
Rainier is the cousin yeah Rainier is
the cousin it's all very complicated I'd
be so mad like so when you guys were you
guys were [ __ ] on the beach
but while that was going on we were
falling in love uh and that's how you
make a Targaryen Brady Bunch this is the
story of a lovely lady who had three
boys of her own uh and there's a father
with two girls and he doesn't have
someone and then they might consummate
and they all get together there's
probably a maid involved and that's the
target Bunch
very crazy very crazy well before we get
into all of our big questions and uh top
us a discussion for this episode we want
to remind you to check out new
rockstarsmerch.com where you can grab
our newest latest Obsession shirt Ashton
ruin inspired by house of the Dragon
this limited edition shirt won't be
available for much longer so be sure to
grab one before it's locked away in a
stone casket and tossed into the sea
never to be seen again and when you
purchase this latest Obsession shirt you
unlock the ability to get a custom shout
out that will appear right here on
talking dragons so check out that shirt
we got some rings of power merch on
there check out all of our awesome merch
options over at New
rockstarsmerch.com so Jessica let's
start at the end of the episode for our
discussion today okay and one of the
biggest departures from The Source
material that we've seen yet uh in this
show we learned that lane nor is not in
fact killed by Sir Carl yeah but rather
as part of an elaborate ruse to Stage
his death and run away with his lover
beautiful stuff he has to lose his
dreads uh in the process because without
his hair he has to keep cutting it
though because that hair is just too I
mean it's very distinct hair that's for
sure that's a good point he's gonna have
to keep a shaved head if he's gonna live
undercover it looks good but it all
leads us to our big question this week
where is Lenor going and will he be a
factor in this story later do you know
what they were what city they were
referring to and they're like you can go
across the ocean to a city well I was
thinking of my pentos right that's where
he was hanging out there's all the free
cities right yeah that's what I was
thinking he could just do whatever you
want there they don't care what's going
on in restaurants they're like I mean
they've got a little war going going on
it would be interesting if lane or kind
of like joins the triarchy and like
fights against them but I don't think he
wants to be seen in these I don't think
he wants to be seen and I also don't
think this is my also situation he
doesn't really hate her and he doesn't
hate his dad no no no family and like
this is like the best outcome for him
yeah because he was like my man's
depressed right he comes to his wife and
he's like look I've done a bad job as
your husband you know we tried to make
our own kids and it didn't even work but
I you know I care about and she's very
sweet to him there she's like you're a
good guy yeah like this world is full of
Bad Dudes and I'm about to marry one but
you're actually a good guy you care
about me you care about our family
you've been a father to these kids that
are not yours and you know they're not
yours I mean even like when they're when
he shows up late and they're like Dad
where were you my guy uh and he kind of
Pats them as they walk away and they
kind of just like ignore his touch he's
trying like he's trying and he's like
look I'm gonna sit down I'm gonna be a
good I'm gonna be the husband you need
and she's like you're sweet
no it's impossible it's not going to
work out we got a big war coming we just
lost vegar yeah to the other side I need
like I need a stronger husband I think
he's happy in this scenario I mean I'm
sure he doesn't like making his parents
think that he's dead well I don't think
he cares about his dad because I think
he's sick of his dad too because
remember his dad in front of everyone at
the Wake she goes up to serve Carl as a
get your patronage
everybody everybody knows that's what's
pissing me off okay so everyone knows it
makes it she says it out loud right I'm
literally like okay so you guys all know
and every time they call their sons
bastards why aren't you guys fighting
why aren't you guys fighting for them
you know why they're all bastards like
that it's pissing me off that no one's
defending her that much but at the end
when we see them clearly take sides I'm
like okay we know where the valerians
stand so in in the source material Fire
and Blood and this is in a spoiler this
is just what happens in the book in
these events
um Carl sir Carl and Lena are getting a
fight in spice town I believe yeah
around this time and Leonor is killed
some people think like sir Carl does it
because uh he you know he's found a new
lover and laner is jealous and they
attack each other uh there's this
gesture known as mushroom who tells the
story that Damon pays off sir Carl to do
these things kind of what we see in this
show but the show has the added twist
that like oh you know because it did
seem like oh is Rainier really going
through this very heavy plan uh and why
she's kind of doing she's talking to
Damon while we see this all playing out
and she says like I'm not going to be a
tyrant meanwhile we see like what we
assume is the murder of Lenor happening
but it doesn't happen yeah she cares and
she like lets him get away and Damon's
also like oh yeah let's let him get away
we say this is a happy ending there is a
servant someone who works for the
Valerian house who does die who had
parents who maybe cared about him maybe
has a family of his own I don't know
that poor guy's dead gets burnt to a
Chris he's just walking down the stairs
it gets choked out by Damon it's not
fair it's not fair to that guy there's
still a not happy ending for someone in
this but seeing lane or get away with
sir Carl they're smiling they're wearing
the uh what is the the uh the Skies of
of Game of Thrones just a hooded
clothing this is like in Marvel when
someone wears a a nondescript baseball
hat and a jacket and sunglasses and
they're able to walk around you put on a
hooded cloak you do whatever you want no
one knows who you are uh but he has
shaved his head the hair is gone did
they put do you think they put the hair
on the body that's what I thought I
thought they threw it in there so it's
like there's a lot of hair that's my son
look at the dragon well they pull out
this body and I was like my wife right
away was like is he not dead and I was
like oh I think he's dead because I had
read the book and I assumed he was dead
and he's wearing like a necklace and
he's obviously like in the clothes and
it's like oh we see this but I just love
because when Damon tells sir Carl to do
it he's like doing very public way and
there's like this little kid that's in
the room
when they're fighting who I assume like
Circle was like hey come with me I want
to talk to you about something and
they're talking it's like they walk in
this room oh hold on just one second you
I'm gonna kill you I know Atlanta's like
you want to do this let's go it was so
strange that I immediately was like
they're well when I saw Damon you see
Damon choke out that guy first and
you're like well I guess he's doing this
to help sir Carl sneak yes I don't know
uh but I mean it is tough seeing Ray
niece
and so and she can't know that late nor
is alive I don't know you know for book
readers the book you know has this
unreliable narrator where this is like a
history of stories told second third
fourth hand so for as far as everyone in
the world knows of Westeros Leonor is
dead yeah obviously uh sir Carl knows
the truth Lenore knows the truth Damon
and Rainier know the truth possibly
everyone on that pirate ship they're
sailing out to knows the truth I don't
know uh well the thing is it can't would
they not recognize him I guess yeah easy
as today where we could be like here's
an image of what this person is and
they're missing and this isn't the drift
Mark or yeah this isn't like the
Valerian Royal Navy out there this is
yeah presumably some merchant ship or
something they're selling out to and
though the book was like this is the
story this is the tale it could we could
still see one person see them right and
it'd be like I know them but I feel like
if hundreds of people know then it would
have made itself in history
No One's Gonna notice but I think it's
going to be someone in his family not
his mom maybe his brother or his dad's
brother is gonna be like you know and
he's going back oh [ __ ] yeah run away I
mean even Corliss was like how could
this happen in my own house yeah he's
like this is my daughter died and
there's I love the juxtaposition of like
fire and water you know what when Damon
and Rainier are talking at one point
they're like fire is like a prison it
it's trapped Us in and like uh Damon
kind of is like I wish we had the sea
you know the sea you can escape that's
like a way out but here they use fire as
an escape right fire has freed them from
their uh uh their marriage bonds and now
they're able to be together uh but I I
do it my heart goes out to my niece is
gonna I've lost both my kids in a small
span of time burned alive I can't wait
to see her again and she's like I know
right near is up something because she'd
be like you went to your uncle way too
quick well this is the tough thing right
they need the valerians on their side so
that they have the power of the sea
right the Navy but for this ruse to work
rainis needs to think that rhaenyra went
through with this plan and had her
husband killed right like so it's kind
of a touchy situation we saw earlier at
the Wake they were not talking right oh
yeah these won't even talk to like
Rainier's kids it is like get away from
my granddaughters and it's like get out
of here you're brunette bastard get out
of here yo son-in-law do you think that
Leonard could come back into this
somehow no like later on you don't think
we'll ever see them again I like the no
and also because of what the book tells
it's like that's what everyone believes
so it's just going to be a long tall
tale of like what happened to her first
husband it's like he died by his lover
yeah like that's what we that's yeah you
either hear kind of apocryphal stories
or you hear multiple stories and the
book is like we don't know which is true
but these are your five eyes I think
that's what it's gonna be I think that's
what it's going to be and maybe we'll
see someone run into them
um or they're gonna die eventually like
farming online then the story's just
said there it's cool without spoiling
anything for people who haven't read the
book we don't want to spoil it here
people die in this world yeah people
will die later and people will be killed
they will die of unnatural causes I
think some of these deaths that we know
will happen could be at the hands of
Lenor
just um the book didn't know it was
Leonard that did it right that's true so
that's how I think these things could
come back that's true that could happen
so I think he sails away to the free
cities he has a fun time because
remember while he loves a life of
leisure and hanging out with his boys
having a good time kicking back he does
say to Rainier like I'm a knight I miss
fighting I missed battle he wanted to go
fight the triarchy so which is why I
think it would be interesting if he
signs up for the triarchy and he's like
yeah let's fight on the try Okay spar
with Carl right I think if he hears that
like you know
shit's popping off back in Westeros he
might come back uh for a little fight
and and see him again maybe not even
this season maybe later Seasons we see
him come back as an older wisened man
who's like I'm not here to get a little
Revenge from myself you know I could see
that happening that would be especially
if someone kills his parents or if he
just goes after Damon yeah he leaves his
sister maybe he decides hey I loved
Rainier after all I want her back
actually yeah I changed my mind I think
I think it could be a factor going
forward and I like that for the show
because for people who have read the
book it's like oh we don't know what's
going to happen to this we can theorize
about it we can we can have our little
it's it's that thing you know it's it's
uh I could see him coming back for like
money yeah he's a loose thread that I I
would love to see come back I love this
for him I love that he's still alive
great stuff I I think it will be a lot
of fun uh and I can't wait to see where
it goes I'm into it I think it'll be
really cool
uh well we got tons of more to talk
about but before that we want to thank
our sponsor for our show today a vast
you know hopefully we'll never have to
worry about someone to come steal our
dragon that writing really wants us and
they steal it out right from under our
nose you snooze you lose but one thing
we do have to worry about is cyber crime
thankfully Avast is a global leader in
cyber protection for more than 30 years
entrusted by millions of users they
prevent 1.5 billion attacks every month
it's crazy a vast new all-in-one
solution a vast one helps you take
control of your safety and privacy
online through a range of features a
vast does have a free version which
includes all the essential features such
as free antivirus free VPN and free
firewall protection and a vast premium
version of S1 has even more advanced
protection and allows you to protect
multiple devices a vast multitude of
features provide you with privacy and
security as you scour the web and even
help with your machine's performance it
can speed it up make it run more
efficiently I personally like their
award-winning antivirus that stops
viruses and malware from harming my
devices as well as their data breach
monitoring that will alert me if my
online accounts have been compromised
and they also have a ransomware
protection that secures my personal
photos documents and other files from
being modified deleted or encrypted by
ransomware attacks thanks to Avast for
supporting big question today
confidently take control of your online
world with a fast one it helps you stay
safe from viruses phishing attacks and
ransomware hacking attempts and other
cyber crimes learn more about avast1 at
avast.com again check out avast.com and
learn all about Avast one and their
awesome features it's really great check
it out okay Jessica another thing we
need to consider with lanor's
disappearance here is his Dragon see
smoke we saw him in the battle of the
step Stones when they were fighting the
grab feeder remember the crab feeder
those were such innocent times it was so
long ago so long ago those Halcyon Days
of men being nailed to wooden wooden and
it was crosses in the ocean that was the
worst thing that was the worst thing
so so he has this Dragon sea smoke he
obviously can't take it with him because
I don't think they can be like hey why
is this Dragon following this boat with
this random guy
get out of here uh we do know and I
don't think it's a spoiler to say in the
books sea smoke kind of stays at uh
Dragonstone So in theory like for this
ruse to work sea smoke doesn't have a
writer anymore and we know that dragons
can obviously take New Riders that's
what we saw happen with vegar do you
think someone's gonna try and take sea
smoke I feel like one of the daughters
should try now right nothing on like
probably yeah
Reina who doesn't have one who doesn't
have a dragon her sister Bayla does uh
but Raya does not she could try to take
sea smoke if she wants maybe she wants
her uncle I'd be so bad still and then
maybe the smoke will sense I'd be like
are you mad because you didn't get the
biggest dragon and I bet yeah I am very
famous
that's my mom's Dragon yeah uh yeah
because this isn't important because
these are you know these are the the
nukes of Westeros right you want to have
as many as Your Arsenal as you can and
we know that you know the Allison and
the people at King's Landing have a
couple dragons so I'm pretty sure that
like
uh Rainier is going to try and take this
dragon as your own because we know that
like you could transport the dragons
without a writer obviously that's how
they got Veigar to uh uh to back to
driftmark like it kind of follows we saw
that in Game of Thrones too right uh uh
Daenerys would ride her main dragon in
the other one just kind of follow along
it's kind of like you can like lead a
horse on another horse you know what I
mean uh so someone's gonna try and take
sea smokers I think definitely Rainier
is gonna be like yeah we'll keep seeing
yeah this is staying with us so they
already left right yeah King's Landing
people have left at this point so
they're going to be like we're going to
keep this it would be interesting to see
if like rhaenice tries to keep it and
try and be like no I'm thinking it's my
son's Dragon I'm hoping in the next
episode that's when they're gonna
actually start trying to combine the
house again right or like more so and
then maybe rainey's can be like okay I'm
a little bit better I'm a little bit
less upset but a little bit happier yeah
it would be fun to see Raya try and ride
sea smoke yeah maybe it works maybe it
doesn't work I mean I'm out of everybody
on the show I'm rooting for those two
girls oh yeah out of every single human
being now on the show I am rooting for
those two girls not only did one get
punched in the stomach in the face uh
but their mom died and they lost their
mom's Dragon they have been standing on
their own the entire year and now their
dad's married his knees and you should
get a new stepmom you shared the deleted
picture of the deleted scene that's
right that it was uh Damon hugging them
yeah and I'm mad that we didn't see that
because now we know in the storyline
it's like they don't want them to be so
after after last week's episode you know
it kind of ended with Damon on the roof
with his two daughters overlooking the
bird
of lyanna uh and it's kind of you know
Damon's kind of cold he's not really
touching them he's kind of distant he
walks away while they're still up there
the official Game of Thrones account put
out a still from a deleted scene where
that same location but he's hugging both
of them very affectionately uh and they
cut that out of the show so for our own
purposes for our own Canon purposes
that's not canon and he has this
distance yes from his daughters and I
can only imagine that this wedding is
kind of kind of increased that distance
and now you have uh you know they kind
of showed that Bayla uh uh and josaris
were kind of close you know they're at
least holding hands or like there
there's obviously something budding
there but is that weird now that they're
like step brother and sister not super
not for this world
but maybe they find it weird you know
the valerians had their own sort of like
in intermarriage stuff happening yeah of
their own because they're trying to keep
their own bloodline alive because the
Larry is gone don't know if you heard
the story
uh but it's all very very interesting
yeah I I just I want I just want the
most for them and I feel so bad for that
entire family I hope everyone gets the
dragon that they want
um the poor black family The House of
the Dragon City wow they're getting up
flip turn flap to upside down thrown
into the water yeah and if you know your
Game of Thrones they're not around for
that so uh it's not going well yeah it's
not going well it's not going well so
let's talk about this we'll still do our
power rankings at the end let's talk
about who has the most power now is it
Allison or Rainier because the lines are
drawn I mean we literally saw it at the
end of this kind of scenario in the Hall
of nine they've taken their sides yeah
right you have the greens on one side
and what we're going to come to know is
like the blacks on the other because you
know while the targaryens have the red
they wear a lot of black as well
um who do you think has the most power
so now they Allison has vegar right yeah
she's got her dad back she's got vegar
uh they also have uh uh aegon's dragon
Sunfire
uh on their side so they kind of they
got a tough little crew coming together
I don't think the high Towers offer
anything
um so they have the high Towers they
have all they have like Old Town they
have old money too they have a lot of
money but I'm also like versus the
valerians who own the oceans but the
Lannisters are also kind of sided with
the kids yeah they have and they have
them also but we haven't heard they
haven't reached back and she was like
every word has already started spreading
that I'm mad as a queen because I
stabbed my daughter so it's like who's
gonna turn away from them but I do think
they still that like having the title
king and queen still comes with like
plus 10 points right so that's why I'm
leaning still Allison still has the most
power uh yeah they have the kingdom like
the armies yeah so it's like the city
watch that's already like an automatic
Temple they got a lot of banner men who
have already pledged fealty to them
though a lot of these Banner men have
also bowed to rain here yeah yeah but
there we we know that they're Keen to
have like a boy take the throne they
want aegon to ascend to the throne now
right or it could be one of the bastard
children either way
um I'm rooting for an airside clearly
because it has the teams that I want
well let's talk about Rainier side they
got caraxis the blood worm yeah right
they have Rainier's Dragon Cyrax Bayless
got our Dragon Moon Dancer who I think
was probably one of the five dragons
that we saw uh uh uh we have where Max
that little baby dragon we saw him
growing I love him um so so we have she
has a lot of dragons on her side in
theory if she partners with the
valerians uh uh she'll have like
and then all the ships in that Navy plus
she has the element of surprise right
they're sitting in King's Landing they
kind of have to wait now for Rainier to
make her move because if Rainier just
sits back and like lets things play out
she ascends to the Iron Throne yeah but
she's got to get there first which now
she's hiding up in Dragonstone which is
a well-fortified place very hard to like
attack them there she's got all these
dragons and she's a tough cookie
her dad doesn't want her marrying Damon
so I'm also like I'm like what is gonna
happen with the beef there yeah when
when viserys finds out about this it's
not going to be he's not gonna like this
no at all he's gonna be horrible I'm I'm
clearly rooting for rhaenyara but I'm
just like they have the men they have
the power and they have the throne
Allison so that's why I think Allison
still has the more power right now just
because she has the title right the
queen and king of the uh seven no
seven yeah it is a seven of the seven uh
the Seven Kingdoms even though the dorms
don't bow yeah the seven and then the
door's like not me uh but I yeah it's
like because it's interesting because
you
this is just me I'm leaning this way
because I'm also like you can still kill
a dragon yeah I've known Dragon yeah so
that's why I'm like with and without the
dragons and that's what has made it very
clear that's like the dragons we should
have never tried to tangle because
you're just constantly more and more and
more it's an arms race it's an arms race
and they have vegar who is the biggest
baddest dragon and can tear apart these
other dragons yes huge gigantic yeah
very deadly so I'm like as people who
has the most power right and I think
it's awesome it's tough and you know I
don't know who's more in the right here
like both women are protecting their
families what they see is like major
threats to their families they've both
been Juiced up they've been told things
you know uh Otto's been telling his
daughter this whole time like they're
gonna come kill your family like Rainier
is going to come kill your family then
you have Damon being like Otto and
Allison burn your man alive like and
they're gonna come through your voice
it's true uh and it's all kind of true
but like we don't know if either woman
would literally do it now we saw Allison
be like cut that boy's eye out yeah so
she's as as you know air points out
you've sewn your true colors people see
you now for what's real like that you
have these things but meanwhile all she
wants is her dad is approval her dad's
like good job daughter love to see that
fighting Spirit love to see you out
there grabbing the knife doing things
for yourself I didn't know you had it in
yet good job also go back to your
husband right now go go be go say you're
sorry to your husband like Ugh dad why
are you always saying nothing into that
man now and he's like just get me on the
boat just give me some wine get me on
the boat stop talking about it
she's like I mean that's me a lot of the
times after I've apologized multiple
times don't say anything we're not
talking about it anymore I have to
apologize multiple times to your partner
you're like I'm sorry and they're like
stop saying sorry it doesn't just want
to get on the boat I want to get back to
my model kit back in my room I want to
get back to my rat infested capsule
please please stop saying sorry
oh my goodness it is interesting with
vegar too like like we said he's a big
powerful Dragon uh and I can't wait to
see or she's a big powerful Dragon
excuse me I can't wait to see what else
she has in store if you saw the like
coming up next we know that Damon's
gonna get his hands on another egg I'm
wondering whose egg that is because
they're still like dream fire is still a
dragon that's alive that is at uh is in
the dragon pit that was the dragon we
saw uh in the last episode when Eamon
was kind of sneaking around down there
uh even Rainier had said if like
dreamfire has some more eggs you know
those those would be possible so it's
like there's gonna be more to these
dragons and I I can't wait to see what
else happened uh there let's talk about
Helena okay and this is a question I
think I have is Helena a dreamer uh who
has made another prophecy in this
episode uh dreamers are very important
to the targaryens they have these
Visions we saw viserys who is not a
dragon writer himself I'm a dreamer
right Danish the dreamer is the one that
got the targaryens out of Valeria before
the Doom right these things are
important dreamers are important this is
not something that was established in
the book with Helena but in the last
episode she predicted that Eamon would
have to quote close an eye before he
would get a dragon when Allison was like
you're gonna get a dragon someday she's
like he's gonna have to close an eye
first close it permanently and that came
true that came true so in this episode
during that awesome wake she's kind of
mumbling to herself and she says like
dragons of Flesh weaving dragons of
thread hands turn looms spool of green
spool of black again we talked about the
greens versus the black is this is this
like a big prophecy do you think she's a
dreamer yeah I think so I absolutely
think so I think she it's been to those
cameras and just her script have been
too on point of like cutting to her that
it's all we hear her say are like
important things yeah so I'm like how
are you gonna acknowledge her but she's
saying spewing nonsense yeah I don't
it's nonsense I think she actually is
seeing stuff like when she was playing
with that millipede I believe it's a
millipede yeah
uh she says like the last ring has no
legs right which some people have talked
about could that be Bran Stark who
remember paralyzed he's the last king
right because they make him King at the
end of Game of Thrones and he's like No
More Kings basically yeah he's like
let's have a government uh so was she
prophesizing that or or does that have
another prophecy that we'll see come to
fruition later
um but the dragons of Flesh weaving
dragons of thread was very interesting
to me so I take it to be like you have
these real live dragons right but that
all they're doing is making
them weaving dragons of thread a spool
of green spool of black it's like these
dragons are creating the divisions in
this family the greens versus the blacks
uh so I think it's very cool for them to
establish her as a dreamer yeah 100
percent I keep looking at this quote
because I'm like yeah yeah it's
basically dragons of Flesh weaving
dragons yeah right yeah I mean it's a
very quiet history horoscope thing where
like you take it to mean what you want
it to mean is it a Taurus
um I yeah it's just these dragons are
gonna be the one orchestrating all of
history yeah and they don't wreck
they're like dogs they're like the
rabbits are just here to burn things and
eat I don't care who we burn to me we
just want to burn anything every
introduction we get in an episode to
Vegas is my favorite thing it's just an
old lady that's like will you leave me
alone stop
getting on top of me stop right at me I
want to retire I also love she's kind of
like off sleeping by herself she's not
like with the other jokes the bird's
just like sitting on her I really like
that uh we also learned that aegon is
betrothed to his sister Helena which
he's not cool about he hates it he
thinks she's dumb uh but I thought it
was interesting how aymond was like kind
of like I would marry her amen is very
much into this like we got to keep the
Bloodlines pure we gotta do these things
which is like a clear line for like oh
this guy's gonna stir Ruckus yeah yeah
this guy's gonna be probably the worst
annoying person yeah it's gonna be a
problem I think like he's he's he's
different now uh which I do want to talk
about that too I I have a question about
that I'm glad you brought that up uh was
Eamon Changed by Vega in some ways had
to be well I mean you think that like
mentally and just like his well conf
because I was like he clearly is
confident now that he got the biggest
dragon he's the literal runs
he was given the pink dread a pig he
brings that up too he's like I'm sure
they can find a pig for you to ride your
pig face beat
s
oh now you got enough fun
fairy family be nice to the good-looking
members of your family okay
don't clip that out oh my gosh that's
gonna get used against me someday yeah
same with mine
uh and I liked and I liked Eamon yeah
he's definitely different this
definitely gave him confidence but there
is that idea like we don't know how the
targaryens are able to ride the dragons
in theory is like well anyone could ride
a dragon but they've done a good job of
cultivating this like mythology around
it we know that like an old Valeria
there was magic involved with the dragon
writing like blood magic spells you know
mythical items like Dragon horns and
things like that uh and there's this
idea that there's some sort of psychic
connection between a dragon rider and
their dragon and like that's how they're
able to bond yes you're able to speak
the words yes you have the confidence
but like once you bond is there like
this kind of psychic connection and if
there is does that tunnel work both ways
where like the dragon begins to
influence you because when Eamon walks
up that tunnel he's the new man right uh
and he's like I'm not taking this
anymore I got the dragon now too bad so
sad you should have got on it's back
when you had the chance I'm Different is
that like vegar like getting into his
head and making him stronger making him
more cunning and angry I'm gonna burn
everyone alive I love that but I also
just think Vegas like look here I'm an
old [ __ ] like I just want to rest I
just want to rest I almost blew this
child like to smithered I was gonna drop
this kid of the ocean I mean we have
like I wish I had a miracle on the
Hudson moment where they fly through the
birds or get a little bird strike gets
close to the water I was like is this
gonna crash I thought she was like it
just like it was like I should go
straight up and then straight down oh
it's so good uh it also made me thought
of uh think of uh recall a moment in
Fire and Blood that happened uh to uh
Arya Targaryen who was the niece of
jaharis so the king uh you know uh that
we saw at the very beginning of the show
he had a niece who one day uh hopped on
the the back of valerian the dread the
black dread uh to run away basically it
wasn't her Dragon she goes she hops on
the back of it and it takes off her mom
goes after her tries to find her she's
gone for like over a year maybe like two
years she's gone no one sees but uh the
black dread no one sees her she's gone
and then one day the black drug comes
back the dragon comes back and Arya is
on the back of this dragon and she's
like 90 dead she's like covered in like
pustules and boils she's skinny she's
frail she's like there's smoke coming
out of like her orifices it's like she's
on fire from the inside and she winds up
like dying uh a few days later like the
maesters can't save her and all these
little pustules on her like they pop in
these weird creatures come out from them
like little worms and insects and all
these strange things come out of her and
like the misters are like we don't know
what happened but here's our Theory we
think Baler she got on the back of Blair
because everyone thought she took the
black dread she she became its new
writer and wrote off to run away because
she was mad at her mom and mad at her
situation uh but that was the biggest
baddest dragon that was aegon the
conquerors dragon that was maegor's
Dragon the black dread that Dragon
doesn't just take orders from like a
little girl who gets on it for the first
time and so there's the theory that the
maesters had that that Dragon instead of
flying around Westeros under the command
of Arya flew back to Valeria which was
destroyed by the doom and whatever is
there now like infected Arya and that
got brought back to Westeros and then
she just kind of dies uh I thought this
was a very similar situation where you
have a young kid getting on the back of
a very big very old dragon that may not
listen to them yeah that's right but
instead he gets to control it but I
thought it was a very interesting it
might happen one of my favorite stories
from the past in Fire and Blood very
cool stuff
um I mean that might still happen with
someone else and it would be crazy it
could still happen I don't know yeah
we'll see how much vegar is going to
listen to aymond uh and if if if vegar
is going to stick around and do what
Eamon says uh my last question for you
Jessica uh when is Sir Christian Cole
gonna have to make the hard decision
what is he gonna have to really act I
mean it's clear he's ready to kill
rhaenyra if you say hey kill Ray Meera
do it but if Allison is like I want want
you to kill one of his kids do you think
sir Christian Cole's going to go that
far like he's a broken man he's he's
soiled his white cloak he's willing to
do what needs to be done he's Allison's
number one like when is he gonna like
really pop off I think it's when Laris
does something terrible Laris is going
to do something terrible in the name of
the Queen and he's gonna be like yo why
didn't you call me
that yeah where he or he's just gonna be
like
you killed you killed strong you killed
Strong's family no I didn't hilarious
did in the name of me and she's he's
okay why didn't you stop him yeah do you
think there do you think something like
that could break his loyalty absolutely
because it's lyrics is a crazy person
Laris is gonna like kill a kid or he's
gonna torture someone that sir Crystal
goes like I didn't ask for that like and
I don't want to team up with someone
that's okay with doing that so I think
it's gonna be like a moment of realizing
or he's gonna die I mean I hope in like
the locker room or something sir Harold
westerling like pulls her Crystal aside
and be like I'm a guy what's going on
man never and even even if he did he's
not going to listen to him I don't know
I'm still mad that sir Christian calls
around that man should have been kicked
out or just don't let him let him in the
presence of everybody all the goddamn
time I know he is literally too close
and when the other guard is like what's
going on here I'm like uh he is in every
closed door with the queen he is behind
every guy not the queen not the Queens
yeah when Allison's like you you're
you're my guy yeah wrestling he's like
what's going on with it wait what
what you guys was wearing to each other
and also why am I not involved yeah I
mean earlier in that episode at that
awesome wake when uh visares is like
good night Emma I'm going to bed he's
like I gotta take this old man to bed
he's like Christian Cole you're in
command now I don't think he wants to do
that anymore I don't think he wants to
leave sir Christian Cole in command ever
again yeah no because I think he sees
what's up and he's like I gotta get I
gotta get this Kings guard into shape
they're out of shape they're whiling out
they're having sex with the Royals the
Royals everyone's having sex do you
think Allison and Sir Chris and Cole are
hooking up at all they should
do you think she's hooking up with
anyone no oh I mean the series
I was nervous I think I was like I don't
want to see this happens to be a
learning agency do you wonder if like
what I wonder is now that Allison knows
the whole truth that Ray Mirai
uh lost her maidenhood sister Kristen
Cole the back of her mind do you think
she's like I mean I'm tired of this like
when you get to do whatever she wants
she runs around she you know her being
like but daddy my your grandson got his
nose broken when rhaenyra walks in and
it's like his nose his precious nose and
it's like hey God's over there like my
full eye just got there's so so much
sewing without anesthetic into [ __ ]
bare skin when they did rhaenerys I was
like okay I can only watch this because
I know this is a fake arm but then when
it went to the zoom out I went oh I said
the same thing it's like it just just
it's a fake on it
brutal stuff the maester's like oh
they're so heal up nice and clean that
Valerian steel Cuts real nice but yeah
Allison's mad because Rainier is just
running around being wild uh and
obviously we're nearest man because
Allison has like you know married her
dad without giving her heads up has kind
of weaseld her way in now has all this
power uh and that that dagger you know
the cat's Palm blade that Valerian steel
dagger that we know so much about has
the prophecy of the ice fire you know
Rainier is looking at it in that moment
is like I have to stay strong I have to
stay in power to keep to protect
Westeros I have this burden on me I I
assume at some point she's going to tell
Damon about this now that they're
married especially now they got this
this cool little like marriage ceremony
uh also like cutting in the hands and
the lip that's brutal that's a lot of
hard stuff guys cut like the back of
your elbow or something no they love
each other it has to be on the lips
somewhere less painful bloody blood
uncle and niece
yeah Uncle nee's husband uncle niece
wife I don't know
can you find that card in the greeting
card section of like the white part of
my niece wife happy anniversary to my
wife niece cousin cousin too much
Protege too much all right Jessica we
gotta we gotta wrap this bad boy up we
gotta get into our power rankings okay
who gained the most power this week on
House of the Dragon amen amen Vega I
mean that's a pretty big that's that's
what everyone's pissed about and then on
top of that I feel like once they get
back there and be like
the
pig with wings
oh my God yeah I think it's him he
certainly gained a lot of power this
week I mean it's hard to argue with that
he's got Vegas and he's like a child so
it's like the next time we see him he's
an adult all those years between now and
then he's with a cool scar he's gonna
have a nickname anybody with that scar
he's gonna have a nickname he's gonna
have an eye patch it's gonna be pretty
cool he's gonna look pretty bad he he
did get a lot of power I almost want to
say that
Lane ordained a lot of power this week
the power of agency he walked away from
it all he's free he can do whatever he
wants now and in this in in this show
where we're focusing on these you know
these very wealthy people of status but
they're forced into a lot of positions
and they're forced to do a lot of things
he walked away from it uh so he gained a
little personal power but I agree Amon
gained the most power this week and by
proxy Allison gained a lot powered
though
let's talk about it who lost the most
power this week you could say Allison
because she kind of showed what she's
made of I was yeah everyone there and
she she pointed out like the gossip is
already spreading the rumors are
spreading everyone's gonna think I'm the
crazy wife I attacked I attacked the air
to the throne in front of everybody
she lost a lot of power
[Music]
yeah I was well I was arguing that uh
Corliss did yeah but then I'm also like
well he he still has his team right all
the power that he lost was just in his
two kids that don't have connections or
well it's like now he's connected to the
two targaryens that were married to both
of his children his son his son was
going to be the king consort which was
like a big deal oh that is also true
yeah so I guess but he has like
grandchildren who are going to inherit
all this yeah and when we see that scene
at the end we know who's on whose side
it's clearly like that scene is just a
show where the territory brands are
probably I know we were wondering
earlier but they're gonna stick with
this plan of Rainier again the throne
and then by proxy her kids getting the
throne and then their grandparents so
like they want to stay there yeah so I
think yeah I agree I think it's Allison
she looks crazy she she did lose a lot
of status there she's she's down pretty
bad I think you know hilarious wow he is
the Lord of harrenhal now he did gain
that he's also kind of been iced out a
little bit you know she said I don't
think she's having those dinners anymore
not as frequently
he gets to ride on the boat she's like
hey you're good he's gonna he's gonna
pull a box in front of her yeah Albany
is gonna be a child's eye and she's
gonna be like I told you I got you some
dessert to go with dinner it's a tongue
I think you'll see that it's quite
delicious a little ice cream so Chris
Nicole said uh he's devouring you you
look and he's just
but also I'm not cleaning myself also
I've grown out my head I like it I'm
changing everything
Otto looked rough I was like damn I
don't know where you been you got your
hand back but you still look like a mess
he was like put some dirt in it you know
you know who lost the most power this
week the poor servant who got thrown in
the fire God turned into a yule log my
guy damn tough stuff really tough I hope
they like pay off the family or
something like
yeah
it's too much work poor guy poor guy
they probably don't even know the name
because they're like who was that who is
it oh it's like Coral is so pretty
decent like ah son's dead why is my wine
empty where's what's his face I'm
supposed to fill up this wine did that
guy run out I'm gonna he's fired for
sure he is so fired we're gonna kill his
family too
my wife he'll never come back we don't
know what it is no one's dusting the
tapestries what's going on
this house is a mess where is that
[ __ ] what's his name I want to say
Jake Jim Jim Jim just I don't remember
his name he's so fired when I see him
again he is so fired
well
that's it for this episode of big
question presents talking dragons a
firing bloody episode that it was be
sure to check us out each and every week
right here on new rockstars Spitting
Fire with these targaryens having a
great time this dance of the Dragons
ain't gonna get any better it's gonna be
a brutal brutal end to the season for
sure a few more episodes to take us out
don't forget to check out our many great
merch options over at New
rockstarsmerch.com follow Jessica at
Lulu underscore Clemons follow me at
grin and Barrick and make sure you
subscribe to big question wherever you
get your podcast follow new rockstars on
all our social platforms thanks for
watching today we hope you have a great
rest of your day uh stay dry out there
stay out of the fire
stay
in the fire do whatever you want to do
uh just do what's best for you yeah as
long as you have that freedom good have
a great rest of your day we'll see you
right here next week
Drew Carey
[Music]